foreign
Baltimore what's up Anna
hi
how are we doing
good good
um so I'm calling because uh well first
of all thank you for taking my call of
course thank you hey how's your New Year
going you doing well it is yeah we got a
little bit of sickness in our house but
I think anyone with kids can empathize
with that yes we're doing okay they are
walking Petri dishes really seriously
yes
um well my question was
um I get I am struggling
um about a month and a half ago my
spouse was dishonest with me about
something
um I'm just kind of having a hard time
of like where do I land like as far as
how do I move forward from it
um because I just really didn't see it
coming and so what were they just asking
about
so
um there you think cannabis products
which I guess is a separate issue in
itself
um like be more specific smoking weeds
taking CBD yeah yeah vaping
um and so he has historically had a back
injury and had used it for pain
um but then before the back end we also
used it um a lot in his young adult life
for like partying and stuff like that
and so
um yeah and so part of us like we've
only been married folks for years um and
a part of that was an agreement that
that wasn't going to be a part of like a
lifestyle and that it didn't seem like a
hard thing for him he sacrificed it he
didn't seem like the hard thing it was a
big issue
um and so I saw her under the
understanding that that was kind of
where we were at still because there was
no conversation you were um and you were
I was yeah
like yeah we both yeah I'm sorry you
were under you all both agreed that he
wasn't gonna smoke anymore right
yeah yeah so like part part of when
we're faced with
um
like just I I say gross not like blood
and guts but just like blatant
dishonesty
I often I go to the mirror and be like
oh I must not have been super clear like
I blame myself
and so I'm trying to affirm you here you
all had the conversation and this was
part of what y'all agreed on is there is
that right correct yeah yeah exactly
because yeah it's a good question if
there's a misunderstanding or
um no no so here's here's what I think
you're doing I think you are trying to
squeeze and minimize how bad you feel
because if you don't you're forced to
deal with the reality that your husband
looked in the eye lied to you for a long
time
right and I don't I don't care about the
weed and all that that's I mean that's a
whole real conversation
y'all made an agreement on who y'all
were going to be and the behaviors
actions you're going to take to backfill
your identity
and not only did he not hold up his end
of the agreement but he lied to you
about it right right and can I say one
more thing yeah absolutely you knew
and you didn't want to know like you
knew he was different or he was a little
bit distant and you didn't want to come
clean either and so you are also pissed
at yourself Fair
yeah that's the third that's fair okay
um so now we got a big mess
right
what do you do now
that's my question
I'm calling you idiot
um okay so let's let's he's not here and
we can't do anything about his behavior
only he can right his actions so let me
ask you a couple of questions one are
you a person
that is safe to be honest with
I thought so
it's not like a I'm not trying to trick
you I'm just asking right yeah no I am I
have
I I have worked in an industry that had
um really close interactions with people
with substance abuse okay and so I think
I'm a little more sensitive
um
to it and so I just I just I think I've
seen it really destroy how many families
stop saying there's something wrong with
you
oh okay
there's not you're not extra sensitive
to it what your husband flat out lied to
your face
yeah yes I have a problem with it
um you have a problem with this
dishonesty
oh huge yeah yes you should you should
absolutely you should and you have a
problem with peacekeeping
and to have a successful relationship
occasionally you have to raise a Ruckus
not like an idiot and not like some kind
of alpha [__] but you have to you have
to raise the temperature of the room you
have to turn all the lights on and say
hey what's going on here you lied to my
face
and it's very fair to ask what else are
you not being honest about
so if that's the case yeah and I I
completely agree with that so that that
was the part of the conversation
um when he finally wasn't honest with me
um was was there anything else you're
learning about and the answer is no like
do you just trust that I don't know I
think I think the path back to trust is
different for everybody
okay okay so some people
um some people like want to check in you
I want to I want to you have to kiss me
every night so I can I can smell your
breath
um every night I'm gonna look you in the
eye and say did you smoke today
uh I want to see your text messages and
read like that's only I'm gonna feel
safe or we have a shared bank account
and I'm gonna review the the like like
everybody's everybody's path back to
trust is different
okay and what I'm going to tell you is
um a you can get out of control with
that right where you become a possessive
lunatic and
that's hard to get to
you have a you I I believe you oh no I I
know you are entitled to hey here's what
I feel right now I feel you're not being
honest
and something tells me that you're
calling me because you think he's not
being honest about something else
um
yeah I can't read there's one thing yeah
like I guess
um
get like online gambling for sports just
became legal in the state of Maryland
and so he's been really um engaged in
that and so
I
I he's the one who oversees I mean I
have access to everything obviously but
as far as like finances and stuff like
that he's kind of ahead of that um and
so I sometimes get a little now because
of this I'm like uh like are we okay
with that like is it just a recreational
thing like
your body is telling you you're not safe
and part of the reason you're not safe
is because you don't know because you're
not facing reality you're not owning
reality okay how much money do I have in
my account like here's how much was
deposited from your check here's how
much deposited was from my check where
did every one of those dollars go this
month
how much do you owe to gambling website
a means like you don't know where it's
going so for instance if I went to Vegas
I would tell my wife hey I'm taking this
much money
to be stupid with
and she would say well you're an idiot
and but it's part of uh it would be an
agreed upon amount that was that we've
already budgeted for that would be right
so that's different than I'm just
sitting in my in the couch while you're
asleep and I am gambling on this game
and I'm trying to pick it back on this
game
right I J I just gave a interview with
[Music]
um
USA Today yesterday on what is just
people are are getting dragged
underwater with this online gambling
it's madness madness madness
um and so something in your gut tells
you something's not right
and for some reason over the course of
your life you've been
taught to shut up inner Anna
so that everybody else can go about
their day peacefully
foreign
okay
so let me say this Secrets destroy
marriage
okay they destroy relationships they
destroy people
that's number one number two
I think it's fair to sit down and be
Point Blank very very clear
with yourself here's what I'm worried
about here's what I know here's what I
think is actually going on write those
things down because those hard
conversations become very emotional they
our bodies take over for us right and
then we start crying and then we or we
see our partner like kind of get a
little bit there we read facial cues and
then we're like no no I mean I mean not
that I know you're not but we start
hedging our bets right mm-hmm
write down what you are actually
concerned about what you're worried
about the things you need to know to
begin to re-establish trust I know how
much money we have I need to know how
where it goes we're going to make a
budget together I want you to hang on
the line I'm going to send you
um Financial Peace University the whole
class okay okay I work here at Ramsey
Solutions Dave Ramsey is my boss
and so the I'm gonna give you the tools
to say here's what we're gonna do as a
couple
this is going to be a path back to
re-establishing trust together we're
going to get on the same page we're
going to get the same values together
we're going to share money we're going
to not you're not gonna do all the money
by yourself we're gonna do it together
every month we're gonna have a plan now
we're going to reestablish trust here's
what you have to know though
he might tell you to go to hell
okay yeah okay
you know that right
I would highly doubt it but like I said
as an option for anyone okay good that
makes my heart feel good I I heard in
your voice I thought you were gonna say
that you were worried about that if you
don't think so great no that's awesome
okay so I'm gonna sing you that
and I want you to read out to him your
letter
okay this is what I need like you
violated our trust
like yes we agreed you aren't going to
smoke weed and all that kind of stuff
well that's a whole other conversation
the bigger deal is you messed up and
then you hid it from me
and now I'm wondering what about our
money I'm wondering about your online
gambling I'm wondering about that person
at work that while you're always texting
somebody when you I'm worried about all
kind of things
and you open the door
and so here's our path back together
here's what trust looks like for us and
again this isn't rage this isn't anger
this is you listening to your body
you're not safe and your body's
literally sounding the anxiety alarms
and for those of y'all listening this is
one of those core moments of building a
non-anxious life
I'm gonna own reality and reality is I
don't know how much money we have in our
account I don't know who's spending what
on how or when and not knowing about
something as important as your finances
are we going to have a house payment are
we going to have rent can I trust the
person I'm sharing a bed with
your body's gonna sound the anxiety
alarms you're going to be anxious you're
going to be fried out you're gonna be
nervous or your body's just gonna shut
the whole thing down you're going to
depress
your body's gonna try to take care of
you
when it recognizes Danger
and Anna trust your guts for the first
time trust your guts I think you're
right on this one
hang on the line here and Jenna's gonna
take care of you and get you uh uh
signed up for Financial Peace University
and give you all a path out of this
thing together